back everybody more evidence has come to
light in the Bryan laundry Patito civil
lawsuit new court filings show that a
letter from laundry's mother alluded to
baking a cake with a shiv inside of it
petito's parents are suing the laundries
and their family attorney for
intentional infliction of emotional
distress they claim that the trio had
the hid the fact that petito was dead
and instead released misleading
statements to the public potato and
laundry embarked on a cross-country road
trip in July of 2021 two months later in
September laundry returned home from the
trip alone and patito's body was found
on the outskirts of a Wyoming national
park the following month laundry's
remains were found in a park nearest
Florida home with a journal confessing
to the murder and one of the most talked
about pieces of evidence in the case is
a letter collected by the FBI with an
envelope titled Burn After Reading it
was written by Brian's mother Roberta
laundry according to the plaintiff's new
court filings references in the letter
include bringing a shovel to help bury a
body and baking a cake with a shin shiv
in it if Brian were to end up in prison
Roberta publicly addressed that letter
earlier this year claiming it had
nothing to do with potato in fact she
says it was written months before the
road trip even began the letter will be
addressed in a hearing later this month
Brian let's talk about it so baking a
shiv into a cake offering to bury a body
that doesn't really look good for
Roberta laundry could there be any legal
repercussions yeah Jesse you're right it
doesn't sound good I mean hindsight
being 20 20. I'm guessing Roberto's
laundry wishes she didn't pen these
letters but timing is everything I
understand what Pat O'Reilly now he is
the attorney representing Joe Patito and
Nicole Schmidt is saying that a
reasonable inference is that the letter
was ran out of time when Gabriel patillo
was yet to be unburied and so Brian
laundry could go to jail for the crime
of murder basically saying hey I'll
cover this up for you we can bury the
body that that kind of a plan if that's
true and the timing suggests that she
knew what was going on with guy with
potato then you're not just talking
about the emotional intentional
emotional infliction in the civil case
but you're also talking about covering
up a crime so timing is important we'll
see if they can connect the dots though
well Terry the laundries are seeking a
protective order to prevent production
of the letter you think the Judge should
Grant the motion no I don't Jesse I
think he should deny it and here's why
if you want a protective order you have
to show that it's either confidential
privileged or somehow proprietary here
they're not claiming that they're
claiming that it is not relevant and I
think that's wrong too even if they were
to have that sort of argument Listen to
As far as the judge was concerned it is
relevant because we're talking about
intentional infliction of emotional
distress if we have some document that
is stating that you can cover up the
body here's the shovel we'll help you
we'll help you get out of jail all of
that is going to say somehow whether or
not there is intentional infliction of
emotional distress so I think it should
get in isn't that your favorite claim
your favorite uh positive cause of
action yes in case anybody didn't know
that's that's uh favorite when we come
back an attorney representing the
Menendez brother speaks with law and
crime about their push to overturn their
murder convictions could new evidence
reshape this case we'll discuss
foreign
[Music]
we're gonna be finishing Today's Show in
California where a lawyer for the
Menendez brothers is publicly addressing
the push for an overturned conviction
Eric and Lyle Menendez shot their mother
and father inside their Beverly Hills
mansion in 1989. the two never denied
the killings they testified that their
father Jose Menendez had been sexually
abusive and said that they killed their
parents out of fear but now decades
later attorneys say there's new evidence
that has just come to light that
warrants reopening the case during their
first trial the jurors couldn't decide
between murder and manslaughter so a
second trial started in 1995 with much
less testimony about the molestation
allegations both men were convicted of
first-degree murder and conspiracy they
were given life in prison with no chance
of parole they've tried appealing their
sentences before but it has never worked
well now their lawyers are bringing up
two new pieces of evidence the first one
is a 20 year old letter written by Eric
Menendez detailing the molestation the
second is a sexual assault claim from an
additional male accuser who was part of
the boy band menudo you see Menendez was
a record label executive who worked
closely with the group one of the major
players in this case is prominent
criminal defense attorney Mark garagos
this week long crimes Anjanette Levy had
a chance to speak with him about the
Quest for an overturned conviction
were hopeful that the superior court
judge in which this is in the LA Spirit
Court will issue an order to show cause
or direct the DA's office to reply to
this and so a number of variations can
happen but we're hoping to at least get
a hearing or an order that will give us
a hearing and somebody much more clever
than me said think about this if this
case from the 90s was tried today do you
think for a minute that somebody would
exclude the abuse it wouldn't happen not
in today's menu back in the 90s I can
understand it combined with a district
attorney who was under siege after a
acquittal on O.J Simpson and did not
want another high-profile loss uh then
take the somebody else said to me the
other day if these were the Menendez
sisters instead of the Menendez brothers
they would not be in custody I mean
they've been in 30 33 years I think if
you fast forward from the 90s to now
there is a I said it before I'll say it
again a sea change in how we view these
things and if you look through today's
prism I think anybody will understand
that hey this was a manslaughter uh at
best some interesting comments there so
Terry if the brothers are granted a new
trial how can the prosecution prove
again that the killings were murder and
not manslaughter well they're going I
have to really show that this was
premeditated or it had some sort of
malice a forethought and I think they
have a chance of doing that even if this
other testimony gets into the case and
they're going to have to really show
that the behavior and I think some of
the behavior after the murders were
behaviors that they could look into and
say look this wasn't because they were
afraid or because they were abused they
were spending this money they didn't
seem upset they were cool calm and
collected they did not seem like people
who were afraid and who would commit
murder to protect themselves or because
they were afraid that they'd have some
sort of issue as far as their father was
concerned the other issue is they also
kill their mothers so they are killing
people that they don't necessarily need
to do because of whatever Rage or
whatever they wanted to do for the
financial reasons so I do think there's
an opportunity here even if in fact they
are granted a new child for these
prosecutors to say had nothing to do
with this abuse it had to do with they
wanted that money well Brian Your Mark
Ergo say that if the original case was
tried today abuse evidence wouldn't have
been excluded do you agree with that I
do agree Jesse and it's just based on
how the courts typically work along with
society and science for example we learn
things about science Society accepts
them and then 20 some odd years later
the courts catch up think about it what
do we know about Child Development about
what sexual assault does to a child as
they're growing up especially from
someone who's supposed to be protecting
them like a parent or guardian and his
point is not lost on me that if this was
the Menendez sisters it couldn't I think
would be a lot different and the ability
to make that what about ISM argument of
hey if these were young girls who fought
back and killed their abuser would you
have the same sentiment as it being
young men who did it then I think it all
helps in terms of arguments the jury's
understanding of these and also the
science that you can prove in court I
think it'll help to get the evidence in
I think it'll help to convince a jury
and they couldn't do the first trial
they had to limit it for the second
trial the third trial might be the win
for them all right I mean I think it was
interesting about the politics too Brian
Terry thank you so much everyone out
there thanks for joining us here on the
daily we're going to see you next time
as we discuss Justice in America
foreign